Es war ein Sommertag im Jahr 2016,
hoch über dem Urnersee.
Für den 62-jährigen Sepp Gisler
ein schwarzer Tag:
Der erfahrene Wildheuer
stürzt im stotzigen Abhang
und fällt über die Felskante
300 m tief in den Tod.
* Beklemmende Musik *
Wie all die Jahre zuvor
steigt Sepp Gisler auch diesen Sommer
auf zum Wildheuen.
In die Wildi, wie sie hier sagen.
Begleitet wird er
von seiner Tochter Julia.
Planggen heissen die Abhänge,
die viel zu steil sind,
um Vieh darauf weiden zu lassen.
Als Heuwiesen lassen sie sich nutzen,
wenn man Knochenarbeit und Gefahr
nicht scheut.
Julia macht auswärts
eine Lehre als Landwirtin.
An ihren freien Tagen hilft sie
dem Vater beim Wildheuen.
Wo's geht,
nutzt Sepp die Mähmaschine.
Sie verlangt Kraft und Geschick,
bringt aber auch Erleichterung.
Man muss das abschätzen können.
Wir kennen das Gebiet und wissen,
wo man die Maschinen nutzen kann.
Irgendwo geht es dann nicht mehr.
Man muss darauf achten,
dass man wieder rauskommt.
Nach unten geht es oft nicht mehr,
weil es zu steil ist,
und nach oben kommst du nicht.
Es ist aber noch nie passiert,
dass ich nicht mehr rauskam.
Sepp trägt über
dem festen Zackenkranz der Schuhe
auch noch Steigeisen.
Denn die Abhänge am Rophaien
sind sehr steil
und das geschnittene Gras ist
oft feucht und rutschig.
Man muss auf die Schuhe achten
und darauf, sicheren Boden zu haben.
Wenn man umfällt und rutscht,
nichts mehr tun kann,
geht es schnell.
Jemand, der sich solches Gelände
nicht gewohnt ist,
wäre dann schnell weg.
Es gibt schon ab und zu Unfälle,
und es starben auch schon Leute,
weil sie nichts mehr tun konnten.
Wenn man fällt, dann geht's schnell.
Der Axen am Urnersee.
Ein Felsklotz von nationaler
Bedeutung könnte man sagen.
Durch ihn hindurch führen
die Tunnel der Gotthardbahn,
sowie die Axenstrasse.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Und drei landeswichtige Stromlei-
tungen ziehen sich über den Buckel.
* Verträumte Musik *
Da oben wohnen die Gislers,
auf dem Oberaxen,
der nur mit der Seilbahn
erreichbar ist.
Oder gar nur zu Fuss, wenn der Föhn
wieder mal so stürmisch tobt,
dass die Seilbahnkabine
besser in der Station bleibt.
Bäuerin Pia Gisler
ist im Tal unten aufgewachsen.
Die Liebe zu Sepp
hat sie 1979 in die Höhe geführt.
Ich war verliebt, und Liebe
macht ja normalerweise blind.
Und ich war sehr blind.
Was heisst blind?
Hast du etwas bereut?
Nein,
mir hat das nie etwas ausgemacht.
Tiere mochte ich auch immer.
Natürlich war vieles neu für mich,
aber ich war auch gerne draussen,
auf dem Land,
das hat mich nie gestört.
Und wenn der Föhn die Bahn blockiert,
der Oberaxen abgeschnitten ist?
Dann bleibt man zu Hause
oder geht zu Fuss.
Wir hatten ja auch lange
kein Telefon,
erst ab dem fünften Kind dann.
Das war ein riesiger Luxus.
So konnte man sich
immer noch steigern.
Das ist doch auch schön.
Flüelen, am Fusse des Axen.
Die katholische Kirchgemeinde
hat zu einem Jubiläumsfest geladen.
* Aufgestellte Volksmusik *
Sepp Gisler - unter
Volksmusikfreunden als Axiger Sepp
weitherum bekannt -
spielt mit seinem Familientrio.
Zwei seiner sechs Kinder
begleiten ihn.
Julia und Dominik,
der Sohn mit Downsyndrom.
* Applaus *
Da oben darfst du nicht drücken.
Weisst du, nur auf die Leeren.
Loslassen.
Und jetzt kannst du
auf diese hier drücken.
Die dünne - da ist noch eine.
* Tiefes Brummen *
Gleich nochmals.
Ja, das darf man so lassen.
Gut.
Gut? Etwas kräftig, okay?
Gib es ihm ein bisschen.
* Volksmusik *
* Rauschen *
Es ist Anfang November.
Sebi, das älteste
der sechs Gisler-Kinder,
hilft dem Vater, die letzten
Heuballen zum Hof runterzuseilen.
Sebi wohnt unten am See,
ist als Spengler tätig.
Doch an seinen freien Tagen wird er
immer wieder zum Bergbauernsohn.
Mehrere Tonnen des kostbaren Futters
sind in den Wochen zuvor
bereits per Helikopter aus unwegsamem
Gelände zur Scheune gelangt.
30 t haben die Gislers an den Steil-
hängen des Rophaien zusammengebracht.
Ein guter Sommer war's. Die Scheune
ist gefüllt für den Winter.
Es eilt. Ein Wetterumschwung mit
starken Regenfällen ist vorhergesagt.
Doch vorerst noch wütet der Föhn,
sodass die Seilbahn wieder einmal
nicht fahren kann.
* Zarte Pianoklänge
und starkes Rauschen *
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Sepp muss pausieren. Ein Unfall.
Ein Sturm
hatte die Materialseilbahn blockiert.
Beim Versuch,
die Sache wieder in Gang zu bringen,
stürzte Sepp von einem Baum.
Als ich auf den Boden fiel,
hörte ich ein Knacksen.
Der Fuss stand schön quer ab.
Ich habe natürlich gleich gemerkt,
dass das nicht so sein sollte.
Ja,
dann habe ich mich zurechtgerückt
und habe den Fuss
etwas geradegestellt.
Ich merkte aber, dass ich ihn
nicht mehr belasten kann.
Da dachte ich mir:
"Der ist gebrochen."
"Das hast du gut hingekriegt."
* Volksmusik *
Nein, jetzt habe ich mich
schon verspielt.
Oberaxen, auf 1'000 m ü.M.,
im heftigen Schneesturm gelegen.
Und der Berg lässt hier zuweilen
auch Lawinen krachen.
Die kommen von da hinten,
vom Rophaien runter.
Früher gingen sie bis zum See
oder an die Strasse runter.
Wir sind hier aber sicher,
der Schnee geht hinten runter.
Der Fussweg nach Flüelen aber,
der wäre jetzt nicht mehr so sicher.
Da müsste man aufpassen.
Zieh den aus.
Das muss erst weg,
dann nach unten ziehen.
Zieh diesen an.
Ja, der riecht etwas.
Sepp führt einen Biobetrieb
mit Fleischproduktion.
Eigene Kälber
werden bis zur Schlachtreife
in Muttertierhaltung herangezogen.
Alles mit eigenem Heu -
ohne Futterzukauf.
Allein der sommerliche Heuertrag
bestimmt,
wie viele Tiere im Stall stehen.
Im Winter, mit diesem Wetter,
hat man am meisten Zeit.
Das ist natürlich schön, wenn man
sich so mit ihnen beschäftigen kann.
Sie kennen dich
und sind entsprechend zahm.
Sie sind umgänglich,
und das ist das, was ich immer tue:
streicheln und mit ihnen sprechen.
Das ist unsere Beziehung,
das ist herrlich so,
das muss ich sagen.
Ja, da hält er gut hin.
Gelegentlich fährt Sepp zum Skifahren
auf die Eggberge,
auf der anderen Talseite.
Von hier wirken die Planggen
am Rophaien, die Wildheugebiete,
ganz besonders stotzig -
fast senkrecht.
Es ist schon eindrücklich,
das denke ich oft,
wenn ich im Winter rüberschaue.
Das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig,
wenn man da so mittendrin ist.
Achtung, fertig, los!
Jawohl!
Nicht zu schnell, okay?
Da kannst du durchfahren.
Komm, fahr mir nach!
Jawohl, so ist gut.
Du könntest das schon,
wenn du wolltest.
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Doch, ich bin überrascht,
dass er es so weit geschafft hat.
Das ist fast einfacher als gehen.
- Das glaube ich gerne.
Wegen seines Herzens muss er
manchmal auch etwas zurückhalten.
Aber fahren geht gut.
Du darfst schon fahren.
Nicht rückwärts,
du musst eine Kurve machen!
Vorwärts fahren, nicht seitwärts!
Ich will rutschen!
- Du willst rutschen?
Ach, wirklich?
So weiter, Dominik?
Mach einen Bogen - los, los!
Kurs halten!
Bumms!
* Sepp lacht. *
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
So, jetzt hoch.
Nimm die Ski weg.
Nicht rückwärts!
Dort hinfahren.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Es ist Frühling geworden
auf dem Oberaxen.
Sepp setzt den Zaun.
Es ist ein besonderer Tag,
denn heute lässt er die Kälber
erstmals nach der Winterpause
aufs frische Gras.
Es ist sehr kurzweilig -
abnormal kurzweilig.
Und lebhaft. Wenn sie so ...
Man sieht sie aufwachsen.
Wenn alles gut läuft und sie gesund
sind, ist das klar etwas Schönes.
Das sind immer
die schönsten Momente,
im Frühling, wenn sie raus dürfen.
So ist es schon schön.
Diese Kälber, sie sind der
grosse Bauernstolz von Sepp Gisler.
* Alphornklänge *
Der Föhn
lässt das Wetter schnell kippen.
Wettermässig muss der Bauer
in diesen Tagen mit allem rechnen.
Ostersonntag im April:
Das Restaurant Oberaxen,
etwas oberhalb der Scheune gelegen,
hat zur Saisoneröffnung
mit Musik geladen.
Doch so hat man sich die österliche
Wiedereröffnung nach der Winterpause
nicht vorgestellt.
Julia muss das Konzert
vorzeitig verlassen.
In ihrem Lehrbetrieb hat sie heute
Abend noch Stallarbeit zu verrichten.
Dass sie Landwirtin werden will,
wusste sie eigentlich schon immer.
Ich hatte immer gerne
mit Tieren zu tun.
Ziegen z.B.
kannte ich ja auch von früher.
Auch das Vieh.
Mir gefällt
die Herausforderung einfach.
Ich habe auch
in anderen Berufen geschnuppert,
hatte aber das Gefühl,
dass es mir zu langweilig war.
Mir gefällt es so.
39 Kühe wollen auch
an einem Feiertag gemolken werden.
Dank des Melkstandes benötigt Julia
dafür nicht viel länger als 1 Std.
An der Tankstelle in Flüelen
ist Sepp auch schon für einen
Hamsterkäufer gehalten worden.
Doch das ist die einzige Möglichkeit,
Diesel auf den Oberaxen zu bekommen:
Kanister um Kanister.
Längst wünscht sich Sepp
eine andere Verbindung ins Tal.
Ein Zufahrtsstrasse
wäre natürlich notwendig.
So wie wir macht das heute
eigentlich niemand mehr.
Das so
mit den Bahnen zu transportieren,
v.a. auch die schwereren Kälber,
das Material -
das ist sehr aufwendig.
Ich glaube, damit ist jetzt Schluss.
Über 500 Höhenmeter
trennen unten und oben.
Ja, das sind Welten.
Wenn man oben wohnt,
möchte man nicht unten sein,
und die unten fragen immer,
ob uns nicht langweilig sei,
so ohne andere Leute.
Aber wir treffen ja auch
andere Leute, wir gehen auch da hin.
Aber wenn man sich gewohnt ist,
oben zu wohnen, will man oben sein.
Neun Monate alt ist der Muni.
Heute ist sein letzter Tag
auf dem Oberaxen.
Ich trainiere den etwas, damit er
sich an das Halfter gewöhnt.
Weil er morgen geht,
muss ich mit ihm auf die Seilbahn.
Das ist meist nicht so einfach,
deshalb nehme ich ihn ans Halfter
und gehe ein paar Runden mit ihm,
damit er sich daran gewöhnt.
Es ist nie ganz sicher,
wie die Tiere reagieren,
wenn sie aus der vertrauten Herde
ins Unbekannte weggeführt werden.
Deshalb ist Sepp immer etwas
angespannt vor einem solchen Tag.
Muni sind kräftig,
können gefährlich sein.
Doch auch diesmal
ist es Sepp offenbar geglückt,
ein handzahmes Tier heranzuzüchten.
Wenn sie so angenehm sind,
ist es manchmal schon schwer,
sie wegzugeben -
aber was will man auch anderes?
Man kann nicht alle behalten.
Und auch das graue Muttertier scheint
Abschied zu nehmen von seinem Kalb.
* Muntere Volksmusik *
Nimm da!
Nicht alle hier raus.
Lass ihn nicht raus!
Geh zur Seite!
So, hochheben! Ganz fest.
Es geht gleich los.
* Aufmunternde Klänge *
Greif da nicht rein!
Nimm die Wolle noch nicht!
Hoppla!
Es ist besser, sie festzubinden,
als Kratzer im Gesicht abzukriegen.
Am frühen Morgen bringt Sepp
den jungen Muni mit der Bahn ins Tal.
Ja, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit ihm,
die Fahrt ging eigentlich sehr gut.
Solche Muni
sind aber an der oberen Grenze.
Vom Gewicht her?
- Genau.
Und auch vom Platz in der Bahn her.
Und ich selbst
muss ja auch noch mitfahren.
Ich muss sie beruhigen können.
Sie sollen nicht allein sein.
Dann geht es eigentlich schon.
Es ist aber natürlich nicht ver-
gleichbar mit einem Viehanhänger.
Es ist immer ein gewisses Risiko.
Es ist ein bisschen Nervensache.
Der Muni macht die letzte Reise
in den Schlachthof von Altdorf
gelassen mit.
Es scheint, als hätten
die gemeinsamen Gehübungen am Vortag
tatsächlich etwas geholfen.
Na dann, tschüss.
- Tschau. - Tschüss.
Man muss sich etwas distanzieren
in diesen Momenten.
Es ist einfach so,
dass man nicht mehr viel
mit den Tieren anfangen kann,
wenn sie sich einmal
erschreckt haben.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass er viel gemerkt hat.
Jetzt aber fragt er sich vielleicht
schon, was als Nächstes kommt.
Aber das können sie ja nicht wissen.
Also, bist du bereit?
Wir versuchen das jetzt einmal.
Das hier ist der Ton.
* Langgezogener Ton *
Etwas höher.
Nach oben. Genau, etwa da.
Das sollte stimmen.
Jetzt nach unten stossen.
Nach unten rutschen!
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Gut!
Du kannst es ja.
Doch, das war gut - tipptopp.
Ja, wir üben immer wieder
für eine halbe Stunde.
Zu lange darf man nicht,
sonst kann er nicht mehr folgen.
Es wird ihm zu viel.
Jawohl.
Stärker.
Ich höre fast nichts.
Gib es ihm einfach!
Weisst du, ich möchte,
ich  m u s s  dich auch hören.
Verstehst du?
Bei lustigen Dingen
lernt er schneller.
Wenn es etwas ernster wird,
merkt man automatisch,
dass es vielleicht
etwas zu weit geht.
Aber plötzlich macht er dann doch
etwas, das man nicht erwartet hätte.
Und wenn man dann einmal richtig
spielt und Publikum vor sich hat,
ist es sowieso anders,
dann kommt er richtig in Fahrt.
Dann spielt er vielleicht
auch etwas, das er gelernt hat.
Das kommt dann natürlich
zur Geltung.
Eins, zwei.
* Lustige Volksmusik *
Im Schlachthaus von Altdorf
portionieren die Gislers
das Fleisch des Muni.
Von den 350 kg Lebendgewicht
bleiben etwa 120 kg Biofleisch,
das direkt
an die Kunden geliefert wird.
Wenn ich mit der Seilbahn
Leute rauf- und runterlasse,
ergeben sich viele Kontakte.
Die Leute sehen vielleicht
die Kühe und Kälber draussen,
und das gefällt ihnen sehr.
Die Gislers sind Kleinbauern.
So wie sie wirtschaften -
mit eigenem Futter,
Biofleisch im Direktverkauf
und etwas Subventionen -,
reicht es einigermassen.
Sepp jedenfalls will nicht klagen.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden damit,
wie es momentan läuft.
Wir haben eine sehr gute Kundschaft.
Wenn uns diese treu bleibt und wir
unsere Sache weiterhin gut machen,
denke ich schon,
dass das Zukunft hat.
Man kann nicht sagen,
dass es zu 100 % klappen wird,
aber bis jetzt hat es funktioniert,
und ich mache das schon 20 Jahre.
12,5.
Jeden Frühling,
noch vor dem Alpgang, ist Badetag.
So, jetzt ist fertig.
* Muhen *
Wir haben genug Wasser.
Die Speziallösung soll den Tieren
etwas Ruhe vor Zecken verschaffen,
diesen gefährlichen Parasiten.
Dominik hilft, wo er kann.
* Erschrecktes Meckern *
Sepps Tagesablauf richtet sich auch
nach den Bedürfnissen seines Sohnes.
Man ist immer etwas eingeschränkt.
Wenn ich wie andere arbeiten gehen
möchte, für einen Nebenerwerb z.B.,
hätte ich
gar keine Zeit für Dominik.
Man muss immer darüber nachdenken,
wie man die Arbeit einteilt,
damit er auch beschäftigt ist.
Ja, anfangs war es nicht einfach.
Man hat sich natürlich auch gefragt:
"Wieso gerade wir?"
Diese Frage stelle ich mir
schon lange nicht mehr.
Äh ...
Heute denke ich, dass es schön ist,
dass er hier
mit uns zusammenleben kann
und dass es auch funktioniert.
Man liebt ihn,
so wie die anderen Kinder ja auch.
Ich wollte nie einen Unterschied
zwischen ihm und den anderen machen.
Deshalb wuchs er so natürlich wie
möglich mit den anderen hier auf.
Ganz früher fragte man sich öfters,
was er wohl alles können werde.
Wenn man sich keine Ziele setzt
und dann etwas kommt,
das man nicht erwartet,
ist es umso schöner.
Frühsommer am Urnersee.
* Zögerliche Klavierklänge *
In wenigen Tagen ist Alpaufzug.
* Bedrohliche Handorgelklänge *
Mit einer Transportbahn wird Material
zur Alp Franzen hochgebracht.
Alpzeit,
das ist auch die Zeit des Wildheuens.
Sepp wird wieder
in die Wildi aufsteigen,
zu dieser notwendigen, anstrengenden
und auch gefährlichen Arbeit.
Ich denke gar nicht mehr daran,
dass etwas passieren könnte.
Wenn etwas passiert, passiert es,
egal ob man Angst hat.
Bis jetzt hatten wir immer Glück.
Oft bestimmt auch grosses Glück.
Früher half ich auch oft mit.
Es kann schon vorkommen, dass ein
paar Steine neben dir runterfallen.
Da denkt man schon:
"Da hattest du Glück."
So darf er aber gar nicht denken -
und das tut er auch nicht.
Sepp geht mit Tochter Bernadette
dem Zug voraus.
15 Kühe und Rinder
steigen auf zur Franzenalp,
15 weitere seiner Tiere sömmern auf
einer anderen Alp im Maderanertal.
Eine kleine Pause,
damit sie nachher wieder Zug haben.
Es ist sicherer,
wenn sie noch Kraft haben.
Wenn sie an einer schwierigen Stelle
nicht mehr mögen, gibt es Probleme.
Deshalb bleiben wir etwas stehen,
dann geht es weiter.
Der Aufstieg ist steil, doch nicht
allzu lange, eine gute Stunde nur.
Und doch sind bei diesem Zug auf die
Franzenalp stets viele Helfer dabei,
Familienmitglieder und Freunde.
Das ist auch angezeigt:
Der Weg ist schmal und heimtückisch.
Die Begleiter des Zuges
sind aufmerksam, denn sie wissen,
dass ein Absturz droht,
wenn ein Tier neben den Weg gerät.
Ein junges Rind hat vor ein
paar Jahren den Anschluss verpasst.
Wir wären in der Nähe gewesen,
aber es wollte einfach nach unten.
Es war so weit draussen, dass wir es
nicht mehr erreichen konnten.
So haben wir es verloren, es ist
dann ins Tobel runtergefallen.
Wir standen daneben,
konnten es aber nicht aufhalten.
Ankunft auf 1'450 m ü.M.:
die Franzenalp.
Für vier Monate
das kleine, entrückte Sommerreich
der Familie Gisler.
Alois, der Älpler,
ist der ältere Bruder von Sepp.
Er kommt von Kindesbeinen an
im Sommer hier hoch.
Seit 70 Jahren schon.
Und langweilig
ist es ihm noch nie geworden.
Jeden Tag sieht man wieder etwas,
das einem vorher
nicht aufgefallen ist.
Es kommt immer wieder etwas hervor,
da und dort und überall.
Ich bin 70, und jeden Tag
sieht alles wieder neu aus.
In einem Moment hast du das Auge
auf dem Berg dort drüben,
dann schaust du,
wie weit nach oben es geht.
Man hat auch immer wieder
etwas zu tun, arbeitet daran.
Und dann zündet man auch
zwischendurch die Pfeife an.
Ja, ja.
* Geheimnisvolle Klarinettenklänge *
Rundherum geht es hier
auf drei Seiten steil nach unten.
Da muss man beim Vieh natürlich
schon immer wieder kontrollieren.
Wir haben halt berggängiges Vieh.
Einen guten Zaun, den braucht es,
so ist es halt.
Man muss das Vieh sichern.
Abgesehen davon
ist es hier nicht so schwierig.
Also ...
Das Vieh rein- und rauszulassen,
auszumisten -
das sollte doch machbar sein.
Sepp sammelt Holz und Steine
aus den Abhängen.
Schönen, heisst das:
die Wiesen wieder schön machen
für das Vieh und den Wildheuer.
Aus dieser Plangge will Sepp
in einigen Wochen das Heu holen.
Es ist August.
Ferienzeit für die einen,
Wildheuzeit für die anderen.
Das Heu lässt sich nur gemeinsam
aus den Abhängen holen.
Tochter Bernadette ist Konditorin.
An ihrem arbeitsfreien Tag ist sie
hochgestiegen, dem Vater zu helfen.
Ich bin immer freiwillig
und auch gerne hier.
Es ist ein guter Ausgleich
zum Alltag, man kann abschalten.
Mit der Familie zusammenzuarbeiten,
zusammen etwas zu erreichen,
in der Natur zu sein -
was will ich mehr?
Ohne diese Arbeit
würden die Hänge schnell verbuschen,
der Wald käme und die Pflanzen-
und Tiervielfalt würde leiden.
Deshalb erhalten die Wildheuer
Beiträge des Bundes
für diese Landschaftspflege.
Und doch: Es bleibt eine Plackerei.
Jeder, der hier oben ist, denkt sich
manchmal: "Was tust du auch hier?"
"Warum machst du das?"
Aber wenn man unten
alle Arbeit erledigt hat
und vielleicht noch
zwei bis drei Wochen Zeit hat,
kommt man hier hoch
um zu heuen, das geht dann schon.
Wäre es aber ein Zwang,
dann würde es einem schwerer fallen,
hier hochzukommen.
Gegen 200 kg schwer
sind die Heuhaufen,
die den Hang runtergeschoben werden -
zum ausgelegten Netz.
Das Heu wird später vom Helikopter
zum Oberaxen hinuntergebracht.
Sepp ist an diesem Berg aufgewachsen.
Seit seiner Kindheit
geht er in die Steilhänge,
seine Beine sind es gewohnt,
auf- und abzusteigen.
Doch selbst ihn plagen
nach solchen Tagen Schmerzen,
die ihn kaum mehr schlafen lassen.
Die ersten zehn Tage
gehen einem an die Knochen,
das muss ich schon sagen.
Und ja ...
Manchmal hat man
wirklich starke Muskelkrämpfe
oder schläft
nicht so gut in der Nacht.
Sobald man sich hinlegt,
entspannen will, geht es los.
Dann
muss man sofort wieder aufstehen,
sonst macht dich der Krampf
fast verrückt.
Ohne Magnesium würde ich das hier
nicht durchhalten.
Ah!
* Entspannende Alphorn-
und Klavierklänge *
Heute ist Sebi, der älteste Sohn,
zum Wildheuen
auf die Alp Franzen gekommen.
Bürdeli
nennen sie die heugefüllten Netze,
die immerhin gegen 70 kg schwer sind.
Bloss kein Fehltritt,
kein Wanken unter diesem Bürdeli,
das man auch Bürde nennen könnte.
Die Schwerkraft zieht,
das Heu fährt runter.
Sepp steht mit festem Tritt im
Abhang, seit über 40 Jahren schon.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Doch dann kam dieser Sonntag,
der 31. Juli 2016.
Sepp war mit Sohn Sebi und einem
weiteren Helfer beim Wildheuen.
Er stand am Fuss
eines sehr steilen Hanges,
über einer Felskante,
wo ein Netz ausgelegt war.
Seine beiden Helfer
liessen das Heu runter.
Ich sah aus dem Augenwinkel,
wie er dort hinging.
Er hatte wahrscheinlich das Gefühl,
er müsse dort festhalten
oder irgendwie bremsen.
Er ging aber nicht ganz hin
und drehte sich ab,
weil er wohl merkte,
dass er nicht näher hin durfte,
dass es gefährlich wurde.
Und während er sich abdrehte,
rutschte er aus.
Und dann wurde er
wie vom Erdboden verschluckt.
So sah das für mich aus.
Bis du überhaupt realisierst,
dass du rutschst,
ist es eigentlich schon zu spät.
Man hat so wenig Abstand
gegen unten ...
Und es gibt nichts,
an dem man sich festhalten könnte.
Es geht einfach nur nach unten.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
Die Trauerfeier fand in der voll-
besetzten Kirche von Flüelen statt.
Musikerkollegen waren gekommen, um
für Sepp ein letztes Mal zu spielen.
Ein Jahr ist vergangen
seit Sepps Tod.
Erstmals geht Julia
dem Zug auf die Alp Franzen voran.
Die 22-jährige Tochter
hat ihre Lehre als Landwirtin
erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
Sie will den Bergbauernbetrieb
weiterführen.
Unterstützt wird sie dabei von
ihrem Lebenspartner, Hannes Thoma,
einem Käsersohn
aus dem Zürcher Oberland.
Julia hat den jungen Mann
in ihrer Lehrzeit kennengelernt.
Auch Hannes ist Landwirt.
Gewiss,
Julia ist hier oben aufgewachsen,
ist vertraut mit dem Berg
und der Arbeit.
Doch es war hart und bedrückend,
unter diesen traurigen Umständen
den Oberaxen-Hof zu übernehmen -
gleichsam von heute auf morgen.
Ja, es war ...
... ein Auf und Ab.
Es gab Tage,
an denen es sehr gut lief.
Und andere, an denen man ...
... an denen man in ein Tief fiel
und traurig war.
Dann fragt man sich:
"Wie hat er diese Arbeit gemacht?"
"Er hat es mir doch gesagt."
Und ...
Dann gab es auch Tage,
an denen man einfach stolz war,
weil man schon wusste,
was man tun muss,
weil er es uns gezeigt hat.
Ja ...
Wir durften von klein auf
immer alles machen:
eine Sense in die Hand nehmen
oder eine Heugabel, um zu heuen.
Wir durften mit in die Wildi.
Wir durften das
von klein auf miterleben.
Das kommt uns nun
natürlich auch zugute.
Er fehlt eigentlich überall.
Bei mir ...
Sein Wissen
und auch das Menschliche.
Das menschliche Wesen, das er hatte.
Und auch seine Musik,
das fehlt mir schon.
Jetzt bin ich halt oft
allein in der Küche und übe.
Sonst war man zu zweit.
Ich erinnere mich gerne
an diese Zeit.
Wir hätten gerne noch viele Jahre
so weitergemacht.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Etwas oberhalb der Franzenalp,
ein kleines Wäldchen:
die letzte Ruhestätte von Sepp.
Hier wurde seine Asche ausgestreut.
Ein Baum
ist geschmückt mit kleinen Dingen,
die an einen geliebten Vater
und Ehemann erinnern.
Ein Sommertag auf dem Oberaxen,
windig, wie so oft hier oben.
Was in den Boden reingeht,
Kartoffeln, das ist in Ordnung.
Man muss aber
immer wieder gut abdecken.
Wenn der Föhn nur einen Tag stark
bläst, ist der Salat ...
Dann war's das mit dem Salat.
Pia Gisler
zeigt ihrer Tochter Christine,
was im Haushalt und Garten
zu machen ist.
Denn sie leistet sich
einige Ferientage in Irland.
Etwas, das sie sich früher
in der Sommerzeit nie erlaubt hätte.
Die sechsfache Mutter richtet sich
ein neues, eigenes Leben ein.
Es war ein schwieriges Jahr,
das Jahr nach Sepps Tod.
Man musste einfach
sofort funktionieren.
Egal ob man wollte oder nicht.
Ähm, es war natürlich
nicht immer einfach,
aber ich wusste, dass ich
das Beste daraus machen will.
Wir hatten schon oft
über den Tod gesprochen.
Wir sagten uns gegenseitig ...
Also ich sagte ihm oft ...
Ähm ...
... dass alles genau gleich
weitergehen würde.
Auch wenn jemand von uns stirbt.
Es  m u s s  weitergehen.
Das wollte ich auch beweisen
und damit zeigen,
dass das Leben weitergeht.
Vor einigen Jahren gab es eine Zeit,
in der ich verzweifelt wäre.
Aber einfach ...
Aber dank meines Glaubens,
den ich habe ...
Ich weiss, dass Sepp ja eigentlich
immer noch hier ist.
Er ist ja nicht,
wie soll ich sagen ...
Er hat die Seite gewechselt,
aber er ist immer noch hier.
Passiert ist eigentlich nichts,
das habe ich ...
Wir hatten das schon im Nachruf
bei der Beerdigung gesagt.
Er konnte nie tiefer fallen,
als in Gottes Hände.
Und das meine ich wirklich so.
Und Dominik?
Dessen früheres Leben so eng mit
jenem des Vaters verbunden war?
Er hilft heute in der Küche
des Oberaxen-Restaurants,
das von seiner Schwester Claudia
geführt wird.
Wir haben ihm das erklärt.
Dass Dädi gestorben ist.
Er hat bereits den Tod
von zwei Grossmüttern
und von Tanten miterlebt.
Für ihn ging es ganz normal weiter.
Er
hat nie etwas gesagt oder erzählt.
Erst kürzlich sprach er jemanden an
und sagte:
"Weisst du, Dädi ist tot."
Aber er macht das ganz gut.
Auf dem Oberaxen
erwarten sie das wertvolle Heu
aus den Planggen des Rophaien.
Es sind die Wochen des Wildheuens,
erstmals ohne Sepp.
Julia ist mit ihren Helfern
oben am Berg.
Ihre Mutter Pia weiss,
dass es nicht anders geht.
Einfach darauf vertrauen,
dass alles gut geht.
Wie früher auch: Wir gingen nie
mit Angst an die Arbeit heran.
Immer voller Zuversicht.
Nein, ich habe keine Angst
vor dem Wildheuen.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Mehrheitlich
ziehen wir jetzt auch Steigeisen an.
Sicher, wenn man weiss,
dass es gefährlich ist
oder an einer Stelle,
bei der man ...
... bei der es
kein Zurück mehr gibt.
Das ist immer noch ein Stück Heimat.
Verbundenheit auch.
Und ja,
wir brauchen es für unsere Tiere.
Ja, es ist gefährlich.
Aber daran möchte ich
eigentlich nicht viel ändern.
Solange man so davon leben kann ...
... wird es auch so weitergehen.
* Abenteuerlustige Klänge *